unhelpful advice of you they ask a
question you answer it okay okay
I'm hopeful vows with Bobby kalila Jojo
hi tiger belly I wanted to start off by
sunny absolutely love the podcast and
all of you a longtime listener
first-time a mailer unhelpful advice so
this month I've been celebrating the
one-year anniversary since I broke up
with my toxic and abusive boyfriend we
were together for four years but I
couldn't be more happy and proud of
myself for making a decision to leave a
year ago after the breakup I went
straight to self-care and started doing
things for me I got into new hobbies
finally started a nursing program and I
was postponing and finally started a
nursing program that I was postponing
and traveled to places I've never been I
feel like I did everything right when it
comes to break up and I had a lot of
growth because of it but within the past
few weeks I've been having flashbacks of
times when me and my ex were still
together
the good and bad they seemed to come out
out of nowhere the good memories leave
me depressed and the bad memories give
me many anxiety attacks usually I'm able
to take deep breaths to refocus my
thinking but recently it's been getting
harder to do that is this just a phase
that everyone goes through how do you
deal with flashbacks of bad memories how
do you deal with flashbacks at good
memories about a bad ex thanks for
taking the time to read this email
respectfully Clarissa
faithful member of this left kingdom
well the human your flashbacks with a
different event in your life that's what
the mind is there before you know at
least it's not a war that you're having
a flashback on you know it might have
been maybe it was a really abusive
relation to vomit how it is that I think
that I'm not a scientist of the mind I
don't have a medical degree but I have
flashbacks I think that flashbacks is a
part of just a mechanism that what the
mind does and there are some good events
you know and bad events I have I have
flashbacks on [ __ ] that's like random
and and you know I have them on
auditions I have them on what my dad
used to do I have them on we were
relationships or you know you know
different things and you you feel sad
about them and this I mean that I think
that's just a part of having a brain I
can speak to the good flashbacks I think
that that's just the
the normal course of anything especially
when you've had distance with that
person you that that I don't know like
for instance I was in a really really
tumultuous relationship where the guy
basically threatened my life
MMH and I the moment that he was
threatening me I thought to myself God
like I can't [ __ ] wait for this to be
over and to never hear from him again to
never see him again but three years
fast-forward and you start to all of
those super like hard feelings go away
and you're like huh I wonder how he's
doing and it's not real it's not like
you have it doesn't mean anything other
than like a bit of like a curiosity
that's kind of a surface and it's it's
what what why are you doing that okay
why I have flashbacks about any girl
it's not like in a way that oh I want to
get back with that person I just think
it's a natural course of how memories
work you know I have flashbacks on like
things I like one time I shouldn't be
saying this but well I had a girlfriend
who she was like I go joke me off a
little bit and so she she she's trying
to do it I go it's not a joystick and
she went stop and she started crying
yeah gentle you know but I was a you had
a flashback I remember of that girl who
was on top of you and she was she
thought she was like really bomb at sex
but she was doing the sideways or
writing flopping up using the side ride
she didn't go up and down she did like a
saddle thing doesn't even feel good it
doesn't no feel like your big screen
whisperer gonna be so you break the base
yeah that was her only move side to side
never once up and down those are the
worst ones cause like you know when
you're younger you think good sex means
doing sixteen different positions and
good sex could be like missionary and
that could be the best sex ever yeah
yeah yeah she probably thought she was
getting really creative and she didn't
know she was breaking your dick but she
didn't we did it a couple times she
didn't do it there was no other Alt alt
alter different moves and that's all she
does
all she did was like a hula-hoop thing
yeah it's a meat grinder what do you
think about bad flashbacks well I think
she's asking because she wants to find
out if there's a different way to cope
because I think you know listening to
tiger belly and all that it's like
obviously you went through a lot of pain
and suffering yeah and she probably
looks up to you and your advice and and
she's probably asking how do I deal with
it yes you know it's it's one of those
things you just kind of live with it
like it's a lot luggage or you can talk
to somebody about it a professional I
think that she probably hasn't
reconciled truly even if she thinks
she's found closure or she's moved on
maybe there's a part of her that still
feels really threatened by the idea of
having this really abusive past with
this person so she needs to reconcile
with that and speak to somebody you know
I see a therapist Erik Griffin told me
Erik we were having dinner and he goes
yo man you should watch see a therapist
mm-hmm
I thought about it it's really helping
me out they come no I like the luggage
well I mean you're you subconsciously
probably do this but you're you're a
comic so you know how to cope and change
your story and and you know how to make
light of it maybe you have the tools and
some people don't know I don't maybe
maybe I'm saying right now I know for a
fact if I saw a therapist you would
clear a lot of things up and I wouldn't
be so depressed but I want to carry the
luggage you know someone said this I
think it was a guy on the Joe Rogan
podcast I forget where I heard I heard
it but people who are very balanced and
self actualized are the least funny
people like you know think about your
friends who are really Zen and who are
they're never funny never true because
they're too calm they are and they're
like they gotta fart it was so like
miniature machine gun yeah that's an m16
I think that is
you should definitely talk to somebody
and decompress and yeah I'm sorry guys
hope you are all well love the podcast
I'm from London
when will Bob tour England question
never okay I want to propose to my girl
this year or next any ideas how I should
make it extra special Kay talks about
how she isn't a lovely mushy girl
so is mine but I think all girls
secretly want that moment be slightly
special why don't you agree
looking at your thoughts I heard about
the best one last night where was it
because I was in Chicago with Jade
Katarina and Jade has a friend named
Jeannie who is a baker yeah and she's
getting married this Filipino guy and we
all had dinner together right and the
way he proposes Jeannie fell asleep
right and he just slipped the ring Oh
oh my god give me like goose but right
and then Jamie went to the go to the
bathroom and she was kind of looking at
her hand and she saw the ring oh my god
I would cry oh my god that's the best
actually it's the best one right and
then he was around the corner he goes
will you marry me you should have never
told me that cuz you coulda used that
and I he's gonna stick it in your butt
and when you come I think what he should
do to be like a nose ring I think pretty
good marriage proposal would be if he
hired a bunch of goons to kidnap her and
he comes out he beats them all up and
then at the end he's like wait marry me
that's a good one yeah yeah with her I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna have it's gonna
be in a cockroach the ring worst fear
yeah it'll be running away from my ring
yeah yeah yeah
very so I have to stomp on the road to
get the rig yeah and you want to do it
we're not married and I can always that
right that's right genius next does that
it don't you yes it would your overdose
that's your that's your handle Joe no no
underscore overdose it's Joe Jitsu Colin
now on Institute hour it was like
talking to family man